foreign
ER I need help I don't know how to stop
I wish there was some more sophisticated
thing that I'm about to tell you but
Nicole stop I do not buy for one second
that you can't just help yourself it
just happens that I don't buy it
[Music]
yo yo yo what up this is John with the
Dr John deloney's show man I'm so glad
that you're with us
so grateful that you're here we're
talking about mental health marriage
relationships whatever's going on man
your sex life you're just going on your
kids schools we talk about it all on
this show
and it's the best
mental health and marriage podcast that
has ever existed ever I'm so glad that
you are hanging out with this man
um if you want to be on the show give us
give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 you're gonna leave a
message and Jenna will call you back and
we'll get you booked on the show
um also huge
uh help if you will just hit the
Subscribe button hit the Subscribe
button the five star reviews the whole
thing and ah it burns a must sold to say
this out loud but follow me on Instagram
and tick tock
oh my gosh
having Instagram in a tick tock account
but follow me on those on those in those
newfangled adventures and we will we're
gonna make the world right we're gonna
make the world right all right let's go
to Brittany in
Salt Lake City what's up Brittany
hey Doctor John how are you good what
are you doing
uh well I'm not on Instagram or Tick
Tock because I don't have an account so
I'm sorry I can't follow you on there
listen ridiculous number one number two
thank God you're probably the most
adjusted I should be calling you I
should be because you know how life
works that's good man so what's up
um well today I'm looking for ways to
um make friends and long-lasting
connections
um I have huge trust issues and when it
comes to creating relationships
okay how do I overcome that tell me more
so
I think what it comes down to is you
know when I was a child my dad was an
alcoholic and he would get angry and
um he was verbally abusive and you know
if the fight was big enough he would
leave for hours maybe even days and so
you know being a child I'm guessing that
just you know has stuck with me okay you
know he was a big part of my life a huge
relationship that I had and he would
just up and leave and so just I've
always struggled with that through you
know grade school anytime I had a friend
and I started feeling like you know they
were kind of pulling away I I would push
them out of my life before they could
pull away okay
um because if I hurt if I just leave the
relationship then they don't have a
chance to hurt me yeah and so I feel
like I'm still doing it today and it's
not even just friends but it's you know
it can be family members or
um are you married
yes I am do you do this too too
yeah how come yeah so here's the and I
ask you how come
um one of the Cardinal questions to
never ask somebody in counseling is like
why why do you do that right
um or how come you did that here's uh
one we're not this isn't therapy like
I'm just some lame podcaster so that's
number one but the the bigger
overarching issue is
you've actually thought through this and
you've probably been a counseling before
you've done the work you know
and so at this point as an adult you're
choosing to continue this Behavior or it
may be so automated you're choosing to
not seek alternative actions and
thoughts that you know will make your
life
better
so I ask you why aren't you choosing
that
I think I'm just scared of what because
you've lost people
yeah of just creating the relationship
in general like I'll go to the gym and
I'll notice you know a girl comes up and
says hi and she seems to be interested
in you know being my friend and I will
get out of there as fast as possible
okay
and I feel uncomfortable like it it
hurts almost
the suckiest part about your path
forward is the only way to Healing is
through this you can't go around it
anymore
um anxiety's got this bizarre
self-reinforcing mechanism that makes it
amazing
if you get your body gets anxious about
something let's say there's like uh
basketball goals make you really anxious
really anxious and then you start to
walk near a park that's got a basketball
goal and your heart starts beating real
fast and like you said it starts burning
like your body's like hot like I gotta
get out of here
and you run
and you think I can never go in that
park again it's got a basketball goal
your anxiety actually did its job it
kept you from what it had identified as
a threat as something scary something
that would hurt and kill you
and so it won and so it actually
reinforces itself it gets stronger like
Ah that's how we keep her out of there
and the only way through it is in in the
nerd world it's exposure Theory like
you've you have to go slowly be
introduced to basketball goals until you
can walk into that situation
and your body doesn't respond and go to
war because it realizes that's safe
I tell you that to tell you when it
comes to people when it comes to
relationships the only way through where
you are is a choice
that I am not going to push somebody
away just because
I have a different attachment Style
just because when I'm used to when my
feelings were heard somebody left or if
I
um there was a fight I didn't think they
were coming back
and so now when you get in a fight with
your husband I don't think he's coming
back as your body's default mode it just
instantly goes there and so you go ahead
and accelerate the process and kick his
butt out
right yeah and you're gonna lose your
husband fair right yeah Fair
you're gonna go through life pretty
lonely Fair
yeah that I'm already feeling that okay
so what if I challenged you this way
is the way your body has chosen to cope
over the years is it working now as an
adult
it's not okay
would you be willing to do something
different
yes yes it will be very uncomfortable
but correct yes you are a one million
percent right uh have you ever heard me
say talk about choosing your heart
um
I'm coming more and more to believe that
uh living a non-anxious life living a
life of more peace than not
is about choosing a a heart path
because here's the deal it's really hard
to be a hundred pounds overweight it's
hard on your knees turn on your body
right it's hard on your mental health
it's hard on your sleep it's hard on
every on your relationship it's hard
just hard
it's not good but I'm not I'm not
judging it's just hard
and it's really hard to lose 100 pounds
and it's really hard to keep off 100
pounds that's hard too
and so we often get get into a
um
an either or path which is I'm just
going to take the easy path which is I'm
just going to avoid people
I'm gonna take the easy path I'm not
gonna tell my husband what I actually
need I'm not going to tell my husband
that I'm hurting I'm not gonna tell my
husband that he's making me feel less
than I'm just gonna ride it out
or I'm just gonna ignore him I'm just
gonna kick him out
um and not maybe not kick him out of the
house but kick him out
um with silence or kick him out with
ignoring him or kick him out with I'm
just going to stay on social media and
scroll while he's doing whatever he's
doing
um we think that's the easy path
it's not it's killing us
it's killing us
and then the other path feels so hard
like I'm like I can't just like say my
needs out loud I can't just sit down and
look my husband and I say I need this
from you or I can't just tell that
person in the gym hey you want to go get
coffee
because they might say no they might
look at you like whoa weird old lady I
was just trying to be polite
that could super happen and that'd be
hard and weird or worse they could say
yes and now you gotta go get coffee with
a stranger and that can be insane
because they might be a Democrat or they
might be they might be like Trump 2024
and the rest of time like you don't know
you don't know it could be anything
it's not a matter of choosing hard or
choosing easy it's just choosing which
hard path you're going to take
and when I have come to understand that
I'm always going to take the hard path
that's going to lead me towards healing
and it's going to lead me towards peace
and that can only be found with
relationships and with integrity and
with authenticity and honesty I'm living
as
congruent to quote Rogers I'm living a
congruent life
and right now you're not right
right right and with my husband is like
um
as of late I don't I'm not sure why but
even when I go to into kiss him or hug
him he his body like naturally pulled
away and I'll mention it to him and he
I don't know if he's lying when he says
I didn't do anything or if he doesn't
notice that he does that and so that's
been a huge trigger for me lately
because you know I go in for a kiss
expecting this connection and he'll pull
away
and then he'll go in and kiss me
and so I think just lately you know with
him Elise that's that's where our
disconnect has been so I think where
else though because it's bigger than
that then if it's happening just just
there it's happening in other places
where else is it happening
um like with him
um well I mean with kind of with all the
intimacy really
it's you know I but so there's like
there's there's like
um
you're feeling like he's his impulse is
to back away from you right yes y'all
are having less sex than you would like
is that fair
oh yeah okay yeah a lot a lot less
um a lot less okay and it just seems
like he's just not interested at all
okay but back back out of the bedroom
where else is he not interested in you
is he making less eye contact is he
spending more time on his phone is he
working later
uh all of those things okay
so the the alarm system here
the the GPS is telling you here's the
address here's where we're going
but
that's not the like the the
destination's not the issue I mean this
is this is a a whole
it's just an alarm system for a greater
issue in your relationship
and having that conversation as you lean
in to kiss him and be like what's wrong
you don't like me am I not pretty
anymore like now everybody's now he's
got to defend himself you're on the
attack and then you're defending
yourself I'm not crazy right now you're
back and forth that's not the place to
have that conversation
it's to go to another location and to
sit with one another and say Hey look
something's changed in our relationship
what's what's going on
I'm not crazy and have a couple of very
specific
hey you've been on your phone all the
time in the last two months
we haven't had sex in the last 60 days
when's the last time you all you all
slept together
um probably two or three weeks ago okay
um
and I'm guessing it wasn't it was
perfunctory it wasn't uh yeah okay all
right that's what it's been like lately
okay and I've I've expressed to him
until
um he's actually going to the night
shift here soon and I've expressed to
him how you know we've been kind of
struggling in that area or at least I
have
um and my concerns with that and so back
at Christmas he
um he said he put a lot of thought into
this and he thought this would really
help me and so he actually got me a
vibrator yeah
and was like here you can do that
um and so that was really uncomfortable
for me and it made me even feel more
lonely because it was like no I want
that connection with you right did you
tell them that
yeah okay
the conversation like he's not feeling
the same as me he's happy whenever I
talk to him he's happy where he's at in
his life
um
and I'm just like I'm it's like I'm
we're looking for him here's how I know
he's not happy because his wife isn't
happy with him
his wife doesn't like him
yeah you don't like him and he is
increasingly and if you don't like
yourself often I don't like me and that
is reflected out onto other people don't
get close to me and the best way to keep
somebody from getting close to you is
for you to not like them back
and I don't know how long that may have
been going on but there's
he has received the message
to the point that he has taken a left
turn and gone elsewhere
I don't know if he's seeing somebody
else or if he is
just settled into this General adult
male malaise how old is he
uh 30. yeah it's very con it's a strange
phenomenon that's happening Acro has
happened for the last 10 15 years it's
bananas
but just this generalized 30 to 45 year
old and older
nah it's just kind of the way this is
and I'm not attracted to her I've put on
some weight she doesn't look like she
used like she's just not into it I'm
just driving her crazy I'm just gonna
and it just it's just one degree and all
of a sudden the car is way on the other
side of the ocean
right
yeah and so there's something about
coming back saying not I want more of
this from you or
because that's like you need to be doing
these things
the conversation is begins with I miss
my husband
and I you're gone
that's where the conversation starts you
will eventually get to whether he needs
to go see a doctor and have his
testosterone checked or that he's
dealing with some mental health issues
he needs to work through or he is just
um
tired of taking criticism he's tired of
any number of relational things that
have made their way to the bedroom this
idea of sex drive Emily nagoski did a
remarkable job of of just setting that
whole thing on fire it's just a myth
it's not real
it's about ons and offs it's about gas
pedals and brakes and it's about
creating an environment where there's
enough gas pedals being pushed and
there's no breaks
and that can be environmentally the
house clean that can be I needed to cold
in here I need it warm in here I need to
help with the kids I need whatever we
need
but it's not about oh I just don't like
it you just it's it's a whole context
and some people are really into it once
a week and what some people are really
into it four times a week or eight times
whatever the thing is you negotiate
those relationally but this is the
intimacy here sounds very symptomatic
and I think the conversation starts with
I
I really miss you
and something's going on I need you to
be honest with me
because to stay I want us to stay not
only stay married but I want to
reconnect and so what is our path back
to each other it's owning reality we
have now found ourselves
six inches apart from each other in bed
but we're six thousand miles away from
each other
how do we find our way back how do we
begin dating again how do I we begin
flirting again how do we create desire
in this house how do we practice desire
how do we create an air of sexuality and
sensuality in our home we got to
practice coming back to each other it
can't just be I need this I need this
because the solution to I need this
is hey here's just a vibrator you can
take care of it whenever you want to
and now you can just leave me alone
because I'm not good at I don't know
what I'm doing clearly
um that's a totally different
proposition
and so
um
I would love before he goes off to his
new job that y'all go spend a couple
hours together
preferably in the morning
getting breakfast together in the
sunshine it's a little bit cold and
saying hey before we make this big life
transition I miss you
and I want you back in my life
and it's not just about sex it's about
texting it's about eye contact it's
about touch it's about hugs it's about
all these things and some of it may be
as simple as my wife and I years ago
implemented in the mornings when both of
us wake up we hug just hug
never occurred to one of us to do that
but we hug it's just a thing and we both
know that that starts a domino
that impacts both of our days
and now it's weird I'm on the road like
I just I expect that I need that it's
just a part of breathing for me it's
part of waking up and it's not there
when I'm on the road and so I can't wait
till I get home and I just get that that
Routine Morning hug that just starts
today right whatever those things are
for you guys
we're just gonna have skin skin tonti
for three minutes in the morning we're
just gonna hold whatever it is
yes y'all will start figuring that out
but that will start with
I miss you
I want you back
thanks for the call we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back and
cue the mustache and Corvette music not
really Corvette it's Camaro music
it's back to your friend's time let's do
it
[Music]
Kelly's just gonna uh this goes so good
with your dragon tattoos just the music
just feels like a dragon tattoo and that
if Karate Kid seven came out all right
so um Kelly gave me these two articles
one of the things I want to do uh that
we've begun doing on facts of your
friends is taking things that are
non-pathological meaning they're not in
the DSM they are not you wouldn't go to
a doctor and get diagnosed with this but
that it's made its way into the
vernacular it's something that is just
made its way into the world and we hear
it all the time
um like I've got overachieving anxiety
no you don't because that's not a thing
it's not real it's not a thing
um so
today she handed me this and there's
it's called hurry sickness hurry
sickness
um or constant panic and Rush is another
way they say it but tell me if this
sounds familiar
um this uh I don't even see an author
here it's just written by mindtools.com
tell me if this sounds familiar
you rush into work late again after
doing the school run and navigating
through traffic
when you open up your computer there are
so many email and message notifications
that you don't even know where to start
then you realize you're late for a
meeting so you rush off half Walking
Half running and you grab a seat in the
meeting room
a few minutes later you realize that
you're double booked and you make your
apologies and dash off to join a
conference call you're late to the
conference call
your day ahead looks just as hectic so
while you're on the phone you reply to
emails marked urgent check your calendar
and reply to several messages and
there's no let up even after you arrive
home you somehow juggle cooking a meal
putting the kids to bed doing some
housework while preparing for a
presentation that you're giving in the
morning
and then when you finally get to bed
your mind is still racing worrying about
all the things you still haven't been
able to get get around to and we'll have
to tackle tomorrow
does this frantic sense of always being
on the go seem familiar
people with hurry sickness think fast
talk fast they act fast they're always
going from thing to thing to thing to
thing to thing
um I
I'm I've I didn't know the phrase hurry
hurry sickness I hadn't heard that
before but there is this sense
um
that this is the age we're in and we've
it it's been roundly debunked in
scientific studies this idea of
um multitasking it's not real it's
impossible your brain can't do it so
when you are listening to your kid
checking your email also has have the
radio going and you're watching a TV
show in the background
and your husband's explaining something
to you your brain is not can't absorb
all of that at one time and make sense
of it it's just toggling back and forth
and so you're getting pieces of
different information you're getting
pieces of experiences all at the same
time and so it's you're not ever
anywhere
that's been the biggest like Revelation
like I'm not really anywhere ever
and I end up driving my car 500 miles an
hour to work uh I I have to I'm running
out the door I'm speeding to work or I'm
frustrated I'm late to this first
meeting and because I'm late to the
first meeting I'm gonna be late to every
other meeting and then somebody stops me
and they're like hey I'm hurting like my
mom just passed away and I want to stop
and talk but I've created a schedule for
myself I've got no margin then I feel
guilty and it just never stops
and then I take that energy and I look
at my kids and that energy is like a a
laser and it melts them they can't
handle that much Focus
what do you need and I hear my
six-year-old my seven-year-old she's
just stumbling through the word she's
like um I uh I I'm like what do what hon
what do you need right and then they get
it too
hurry sickness
so you can't go to the doctor they're
not gonna diagnose you with hurry
sickness
um the more I dug into the research and
where I just landed on my book is this
I don't know
um you've heard me say anxiety is an
addiction you get addicted to it what I
don't know is
um if you have links to studies and you
put them in the show in the comments
that would be awesome
um what I don't know is do you actually
get chemically addicted like you would
to Opium or to heroin or alcohol do you
get addicted to the cortisol and
adrenaline because when you are running
that fast when you're driving 95 miles
down the down the road your body is
amped up and when you're going from
meeting to meeting and you're running
down the hallway and you go in and
you're kind of catching your breath over
your coffee and then you realize oh I'm
supposed to be another meeting your body
is keeping the score as Vandercook says
it's running and running and running and
running so I don't know if you actually
get addicted to the cortisol and
adrenaline
to the
um to the hormones and the
neurotransmitters and the
neuromodulators I don't know if you get
addicted to them as chemicals or your
body gets addicted to your Downstream
response to those things that the drink
you take you you drink to take the edge
off the numbing you do in front of
Netflix the Mindless sex or pornography
consumption the
um that you go smoke a joint just to
chill out or you take a bunch of gummies
just to chill
I don't know
but Judd Brewer's work on anxiety is
Excellence it's just it's a it's a habit
and response mechanism
and ultimately if your body can spin you
up
it can get What It Wants Downstream
which is another drink so here's the
here's my point I don't know I think
it's fair to call anxiety and addiction
I will continue to call it but I don't
know if it's a downstream addiction like
you're addicted to the food that you eat
when you're stressed or if you're
actually addicted to the the chemicals
in your body that are pulsed into your
body either way it doesn't matter
hurry sickness is because it's become a
way of being we've created anxious lives
for ourselves that quite frankly our
bodies can't exist in and they are
coming apart at the seams look around
okay so
um and we'll link to these in the show
notes these are their pop psychology
right they're just
um uh it's
not a lot of like neuroscience and
things like that if you want great
Neuroscience there's other places you
can go on the internet but
um I think it is worth reading because
they they just
they just kind of call out our life the
way we're choosing to live
um here's a couple of things you can do
here
um made some notes Here let me see we're
like oh number one
um know this
flying around the world is making things
worse so stop
[Music]
stop
this was the big Revelation for me
not that I had to figure out what new
planner was going to help me toggle all
this or what new apps were going to help
me talk that's the last 10 years if you
just get the right planner you just do
all this in yoga or and you know
mindfulness training you're cool or if
you just get these apps they'll help
organize you
um my friend Joshua meal burns with the
minimalist says that uh organizing is
just well thought out hoarding right and
you can hoard with stuff or you can
hoard with activities or you can hoard
with thoughts that never stop right
so
I have to know out the gate this is
killing me
it's making me very hard to be in
relationship with is is not helping my
work performance it's not helping my
parenting or marriage performance it's
not helping my engagement with my
community it's not helping other people
in my life feel loved so stop
that's number one
okay underneath that number two
I have to learn how to be clear about
what I need
about boundaries I can't do that I have
to learn how to say no
to my kids
I want to play soccer and I want to do
ballet and Mom can I get a horse
you can do one thing
you get to choose you get to do one
um I have to say no when the boss says
hey can you take on this other thing too
I have to say
no man I I I'm maxed right now if you
can give me one week I'll have created
some space and I can take that on
but just saying yeah you got it and then
being pissed off that your boss came to
you for it
then being pissed off that you have no
more time being pissed so here's a good
example I agreed to a book deadline on
January 15th I agreed to it
I said I'll have it done
my birthday weekend was spinning a hotel
writing
not my friends and family it was spent
Christmas Eve I turned in a chapter
Christmas Day after we opened up
presents and everyone's gonna on a sugar
rush and we I did some more writing
and I can be mad at the the publishing
arm uh my publisher I can be mad at my
dude I chose this
I agreed to it all
so I have to get clear about my needs I
need to spend time with my family on
Christmas I need to have my birthday
weekend so I can celebrate that with my
kids and my wife and my friends
here's what I need here are my
boundaries I've got to say those things
out loud and I have had to learn over
time how to do it and I still I could
just mention I still stumble still fall
all right number three here is a
practical thing never speed only drive
the speed limit
which if you ride with me you know that
you're like I think you're insane
Kelly's like I'm gonna call bullcrap on
that one on a stick
um
if you just for 30 days I got this from
John Mark Comer if you just for 30 days
Sam's gonna drive speed limit
number one I did it and it was super
annoying here's why it was annoying I
had to leave earlier which meant I had
to plan which meant I couldn't just sit
and scroll mindlessly or read mindlessly
or whatever sometimes my son had to go
to school not looking like I would have
loved because I gotta leave and I'm not
speeding number two and this really
pissed me off I showed up to work
infinitely less stressed
I was pretty chill
and I thought oh you got me
because I fly down the road at 95 miles
an hour and then I fly into work and
then I fly into the meeting and
everyone's like whoa
and then I get mad that they're frazzled
it's on me so just decide for 30 days
I'm just gonna drive the speed limit
everywhere and you're gonna get run over
on the road you're gonna have to go to
the another Lane you may have to use
cruise control to practice just try it
for 30 days driving the speed limit and
you'll get stressed at first because
everyone's driving past and then settle
into it
put your phone away number four put your
phone away put your phone away put your
phone away it is adding noise and Chaos
in spaces that normally throughout all
of human history gave us pause times
between work times between action times
when we were waiting times when we were
outside times between human interactions
now we just have that phone and we're
shoving every Square centimeter of our
lives with space and noise and flashy
things and red alerts put it away
put it away
um last one and this is um something I'm
starting effective immediately
is a radical sense an unerant radical
sense
I will be on time everywhere
I'm gonna be on time starting now
Kelly's like ah
I call bullcrap in a box on a stick on
top of a building
with a parachute and dragon wings
be radically on time just don't be late
try for 30 days I'm gonna try it I'll
try we have a we have a jar that we just
keep on the desk here for when I was
late or not and I'll just donate it to
charity whatever's left we should just
do that
remember the whole there was a one point
in time you were going to give me like
five dollars every time you said
something and we got up to like 100
something dollars I still haven't seen
that either so here we go here we go
oh it's just and I would also like to
point out that you didn't start the not
be late thing today
no I starting Anew today okay because we
were we were late starting today I just
said starting now
unbelievable
hmm
guess you're right it is unbelievable
you may need to get a new boss too or
work somewhere else
#just saying hurry sickness here's the
deal
look at your life in your calendar and
look for this one precious thing space
margin a gap in your calendar
and if you don't have it find it if you
don't have it let your needs be heard
and yes I hear you single moms with
three kids or single dads and you're
like dude I don't have to I get it
you're in a season I get it I get it I
get it
this might be something that you work
towards over time
a hurry sickness is drowning you it's
not a real thing but
an anxious lifestyle
an anxious world is burning a hole
through you and those you love
stop
and try to build something different
we'll be right back
all right let's go to Nicole in
Sacramento what's up Nicole
hello what's up
so
um I'm really nervous right now so I'm
just trying to get the words to my mind
Hey I've never lost a a a patient yet I
I don't think so maybe I have they just
haven't called me back but
um okay no I think you're good man and
by the way I'm not good at this either
so same team we're good you'll be you'll
be better at this than me so what's up
so I have been in
children
um
and I'm just really I'm just scared
that I I don't know how to get under
control it's not like anger it's like
my heart pounds I feel hot my eyes are
popping out of my head I'm screaming
I'm spanking my kids out of anger and
I I just I need help I don't know how to
stop at times
uh where does the rage come from
rage means you feel trapped when did you
start feeling trapped
um
children okay
and that can be extremely stressful it's
just a huge responsibility but I chose
it and so I but you that also means you
can unchoose it
yes yes of course okay what else why do
you feel trapped
I just
feel
it's exactly what my parents did to me
and I and I feel like I'm just right
back in the cycle of my family trauma
and I'm gonna do the same thing to my
kids
and they're going to have the same
resentment towards me
and I don't know how to get out listen
to me a hundred percent you're right
I wish there was some magic there's you
definitely one thousand percent need to
go talk to somebody okay
yeah
and until you have the courage to do
that you are making the choice you know
what
more than I want to get well and see a
counselor and talk to somebody I want
you guys to be miserable too
okay that's the choice you're making
but bigger than that
I wish there was some more sophisticated
thing that I'm about to tell you but
Nicole stop
you can stop
you might not be at peace you might have
to walk outside the door you might have
to go for a walk around your house and
take five laps but stop
I do not buy for one second that you
can't just you can't just help yourself
it just happens I don't buy it
yeah is that true
no I I completely agree
from this point forward dude I don't
know how to stop sometimes and don't
know how to don't get to the moment
don't get to the moment that's the
problem so earlier on I used an analogy
um earlier today I was in an interview
if you take a two liter bottle a brand
new 2-liter bottle of like Dr Pepper or
Coke and you shake it up
and then you pop the top off that thing
you're trying to catch all that fizz
yeah because that sucker is so packed to
the gills and then they shoot gas in
there to fill it up even tighter
and what you have to do with your life
is to create you have to dump some of
that coke out of that sucker if you have
a two liter bottle of coke and it's only
half filled and you shake it up
when you pop the top on it it will make
the noise it'll go it'll shoot the gas
out and the the the coke will rise but
it won't shoot all over the all over
your table on the floor
because there's not so much built up
pressure in there you see what I'm
saying
oh that's that's how I feel at times I
just feel like it's spilling over
spilling over spilling it is but that
you've got to create margin in other
places of your life so when your kids
act like kids they're Knuckleheads
they're loud they're emotional they say
frustrating things they try to pee in
the bathroom and they pee all over God's
I don't know what they're I don't know
how they're I don't know like it's just
Madness
yeah that you have some capacity to
absorb that
and that might mean and I've talked to a
number of mothers
that might mean that you've got to put
your kids in school for a season and
give yourself some space
yeah and I promise you the end of times
won't come if your kids go to a school
go to a school whether it's a private
school or a public school they have
parents who love them they're gonna be
fine
yeah next year they're going to a
private school okay maybe we need to
excel I think some major changes maybe
we need to accelerate that
I don't want your kids having another
semester of a mom who hates them
I know I know
but you know hate me like I hated my
parents but Nicole you're not caring for
Nicole
do you see what I'm saying
yeah
because Nicole can't do this 24 7 365
and that's okay very very few people can
but when you take care of Nicole you
will say out loud I need these things I
need space between my kids I need to go
get a job
I need to go be with other adults I need
to fill in the blank whatever your needs
are they can be all over the place who
cares they just are
and those needs are going to change so
they might be one way this year and they
might be different next year in the
whatever it is and I don't think this is
it's not fair to blame this all on
homeschooling
it's you've created a world where you've
gotten no space
yeah you're trapped both emotionally and
otherwise where's your uh is
is is there do you have a romantic
partner in the mix you have a husband in
the mix yeah my husband how's he
participating in all this
homeschooling and the kids is
mainly on me okay um
he does his best he's a fantastic dad
but when it comes to their everyday it's
on me okay
have you said the words to him not in
Rage or in anger but in a private
conversation where you're just being
open and vulnerable with each other have
you said the words I can't continue
okay what was his response
to make it better that's that's one of
the most beautiful things I've heard
it's awesome
now it sounds like the only person who's
not letting this thing ride is you
can you have peace to send them back to
school yeah be nervous you know what
someone's gonna make fun of them
someone's gonna be mean so he's gonna
laugh at their clothes someone's gonna
make fun of their hair that's there's
gonna be part of that and that's why
they have parents mom and dad who love
them
right
anger covers up sadness and points us to
something we can't control
that we wish was different right it
points us to things that we wish were
different
and often anger is our body feeling like
we fail we're failing at something
and it is
and when you grow up with abusive
parents
your body protects itself with a big
thick blanket and we call it a blanket
shame
that's right because nobody would
protect you and they should have
right
yeah
do you want another life
oh I love my life no no no no do you
want a more yeah I asked that the wrong
way do you want a more you want a more
peaceful way of being
yes and I pray for that constantly okay
for peace and calmness you have to do
different things
what we're doing so far is now working
can we agree on that
okay
we gotta do something different
and I don't know what that's going to be
for your life it's going to be any
number of things
it might mean that you sit down with
your husband and you say I have to get
up and go for a long walk by myself in
the morning and listen to my songs I've
got to get up in the morning and
whatever
I've got to have one night a week to
meet with the with the women in my
community whatever the thing is
and I know you commute a long way and we
have to go back and forth I get all that
but I need you here or maybe we need to
move closer to where you work so you
have to commute so far so you can
provide some more help on that like we
got to get radical here because we are
changing a family tree Nicole
and every step along the way is going to
be uncomfortable because you've never
seen it done before and it's going to
feel weird
but it's gonna be right
so hear me say you deserve better than
this and your kids do too so from this
day forward never yell at your kids
again
never hit your kids again ever
and I know you don't want to don't
and start the work go call a counselor
today
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read it I'll also send you
a link to a free audiobook I want you to
listen to it if that's easier
but you have to acknowledge what
happened to you and you have to decide
I'm the person who's going to turn and
face this forest fire and it's going to
burn me and I'm gonna get scars but this
will not continue with my kids and by
the way tell your kids I'm sorry I
screwed up I shouldn't have yelled at
you
I shouldn't hit you I'm sorry
so sorry
you're gonna go see a counselor then you
and your husband are gonna sit down and
you are going to re reimagine your life
from the moment you wake up to the
moment you go to bed and say okay what
do we have to do to make a different
life for ourselves and our kids
that might mean we have to move that
might mean we got to take different jobs
that might mean kids are going to public
school for the rest of the year and then
before they go to private school
whatever the thing is that might mean
like my kids ain't going to public
school well they are now
someone keep them safe and I'm gonna
make sure they're loved and they're
connected
[Music]
never
hit your kids again
[Music]
and Nicole
for the first time in your life
putting a coal up at the top of that
list
[Music]
start loving Nicole like nobody except
your husband and your kids have ever
loved Nicole
and ask her what do you need
be whole and well so that our kids can
be home
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right wrap up today's show if you
know you know today's song is called
Dirty Work by Steely Dan times are hard
and you're afraid to pay the fee so you
find yourself somebody who can do the
job for free when you need a bit of
loving because your man's out on the
town
that's the time you get me running and
you know I'll be around I'm a Fool To Do
Your Dirty Work
oh yeah I'm not I hate Steely Dan
I can't see it it's your favorite band
ever Kelly in the world
hmm
it's not a fan
school is in a Metallica we'll see you
soon